I just sent a tweet out that now is
something you know 100 something
thousand likes where I said hey
Facebook's now worth 650 billion dollars
most of that based on the monetization
of our data at this point Facebook
should be paying us for the privilege of
using our data because they're literally
worth like 2/3 of a trillion dollars
it's like wait how the heck did they
become worth two-thirds of a trillion
dollars if it's free and the fan base
again it's all of the advertisers who
want to access us and our preferences
and micro-target us and access our data
[Music]
yes today we have an important
conversation on data as a property right
and in the middle of this episode we've
got a huge announcement talking about
what we're doing in this arena so stay
tuned it's gonna be exciting I'm super
excited about it
I've been chomping at the bit to make
this announcement for weeks while we've
been working on it and now it's ready to
unveil like I'm more excited about this
unveiling than I than I have been about
anything in quite some time this might
be one of the most important episodes
we've ever had because we're talking
about our data and what we can do to
change the balance of power right now
between consumers and tech companies and
it's a major problem it's a bigger
problem than most people realize oh yeah
it's been cool as you've had we've
actually dabbled on this a lot you've
had Jaron Lanier on you've had even Jean
Twenge
talked about this in a variety of ways
and you kind of touch it on on it with
Jack Dorsey even Mark Cuban so I feel
like this would be a good coagulation of
all those episodes the great thing about
it is this is going to be an
action-packed episode where we're
actually going to be taking action
ourselves and encouraging the folks at
home to take action now what the hell
can you do I mean if you're an ordinary
consumer you do the same thing that we
all do which is you show up to Facebook
or the app you download on your phone or
the website and then
you get hit with this legalese scrolling
terms and conditions' thing and how many
of us read that literally zero of us
read that I think Jaron told a story
about how he met with all of the data
regulation lawyers in Europe and he
asked them how many of you read that and
even they shrugged and we're like none
of us read it all we do is we scroll
down we click I agree and then you
figure well this [ __ ] is free anyway so
how bad could it be and that's where it
gets really interesting is that there
ends up being this hidden cost baked in
we're free freedom is not free
I guess to use an aphorism that people
use in another context or you could we
could change it for the internet free
[ __ ] is not free now what happens is
that they end up monetizing us in
different ways some of them very very
successfully some of them are now the
most valuable companies in the world so
to throw some numbers out there Facebook
is now worth 650 billion dollars
two-thirds of a trillion dollars and the
vast vast majority of that is on the
backs of selling access to us and
monetizing our data now you look up and
say wait Facebook has 2.2 billion users
so how much of that money is from the US
it turns out that a whole ton of it is
where almost half of Facebook's revenue
is from the US and Canada
despite the fact that we're maybe 10% of
that 2.2 billion user base they make
much more money off of Americans than
they do let's say like someone in
Bangladesh or Myanmar or Sri Lanka or
whatever like like they might be using
Facebook but people aren't paying a
whole lot to access their data or
attention but they're paying a lot to
access our data and attention which is
how Facebook is so valuable today now I
I want to unpack a few of the effects
that this is having on us there's an
upcoming election and one thing that is
happening is that our democracy is
getting
corrupted and subverted by the sales of
our data and metadata to various
companies and I want to say I know this
in part because when we were running for
president my campaign accessed a lot of
people's data to like in a very
aboveboard way like we were just trying
to get people's attention and emails but
then what what do you do you end up
trying to optimize dozens hundreds
thousands of different Facebook ads to
try and reach people so that's what's
happening right to everyone and there
are a couple of problems with it number
one is we all know that foreign actors
have gotten pretty good at insinuating
themselves in their creating groups and
saying look like we're we're animated
about this cause join this group and
some of it is Russian interference some
of it may be Chinese interference like
there are different groups that are
trying to gin us up in different ways
now Facebook has been stamping that out
but we know some of it's still sneaking
through and it certainly snuck through
in a big way in 2016 but even if you
discount foreign interference which I
think it's a mistake to discount because
it's real you you then are stuck still
with millions of Americans who are
getting bombarded with various messages
that are micro targeted towards
particular issues particularly
demographics the way that Facebook works
is that as soon as you have something
that works on an audience then you turn
it towards people who have the exact
same characteristics in terms of
demographic preferences media
consumption they call it the look-alike
group in Facebook and so you have to ask
yourself like is this positive for
democracy when it literally becomes a
war of micro targeted messages and
advertising built to animate people
around a particular issue like do we
think that's actually just information
or do we think that's influence and even
subversion so that to me is a very very
real issue like democracy is one giant
cause for concern
in terms of the sale of
data and our metadata now some of people
listening to this at home was like what
the heck is metadata so metadata is the
data about the data like where it's not
about me Andrew yang or about use
diagram and it's about hey this is body
of people and here are things that they
do when it's anonymous
but we know that if these people all do
this and they have certain traits then
other people will do the same and so you
could look up and say well metadata a
timeless it doesn't have names on it
doesn't have like specificity but it's
actually in effect the same thing and so
you have the the data and metadata being
sold over and over again by various
companies to the tune of tens of
billions of dollars a year in value or
more and that leads me to the second
part of this which is that the economics
stink for consumers it's like if you're
signing up for social media networks and
websites and they're then selling your
data and metadata over and over again
and profiting to the tune of tens of
billions of dollars what are you getting
well you're getting ads served to you
right and left you're getting your
privacy increasingly subverted you're
getting potentially your attention
getting targeted in ways that may not be
good for you or may not be good for
society as a whole I just sent a tweet
out that now is something you know 100
something thousand likes where I said
hey Facebook's now worth 650 billion
dollars most of that based on the
monetization of our data at this point
Facebook should be paying us for the
privilege of using our data because
they're literally worth like two-thirds
of a trillion dollars and so when you
ask yourself is like wait how the heck
did they become worth two-thirds of a
trillion dollars if it's free if I'm not
paying them every month and the face
yeah yeah so you're like how the heck
did that happen and you know what's
paying them it's like again it's all of
the advertisers who want to access us
and our preferences and micro-target us
and access our data and
our choices our likes the the things
that we read and consume who our friends
are so that's how you get to be worth
two-thirds of a trillion dollars while
charging nothing like there's a massive
cost baked in and we should be sharing
in some of that value I suggested
Facebook should be paying us at this
point so an open question is how much is
Facebook making off of access to our
data right now and you can find out just
by digging to the numbers like what is
the average revenue per user in the
United States for Facebook so Facebook
is making approximately ten dollars per
month from each of us with a big up
arrow attached to it because that
numbers gone up and up and up it was
like you know six seven eight dollars
now it's like close to 10 and so that
that's at a minimum the starting point
of our value just to one company I mean
I'll be at one of the biggest companies
that we all know and understand so the
next thing you have to understand is
that there is now this whole network of
companies so Facebook Google the biggest
and most conspicuous but at this point
there are data brokers as an entire
multi-billion dollar industry of selling
and reselling our data in different ways
everything from evite to the car company
to the like Sam's Club
you know anyone who ends up developing
this giant list of consumers and some
aspect of their behavior then turn
around and sell that data to various
people in different ways now not
everyone's doing it but a lot of people
are doing it and some of its specific
some of its anonymous how many of you
have looked up and gotten some email and
you're like I don't remember signing up
for this [ __ ] how many of you have had a
email conversation about a particular
topic and then all of a sudden you saw
an ad based on that topic on a
completely unrelated website you're like
you know you're like talking about going
on vacation and all of a sudden you
start getting served up all these like
you know Beach vacation ads like
everywhere you go I will say this Sandra
when we were when we finished the
campaign the number of people other
campaigns organization that reached out
asking for our email list to sell it
it's not a small number there were a lot
now we would our decision was that we're
never doing it we don't need it sound
worth the money we don't think I mean is
a lot of money though they were talking
about weave out a million person plus
email this you're talking about a couple
dollars an email it's a lot of money it
felt wrong and he's the other thing the
Democrat Party does is to man like that
publicly available data when you donate
to a political campaign is scraped by
these algorithms and then I know plenty
of our donors that are getting emails
from other campaigns we didn't sell the
list they're getting it from even
publicly available data that people are
brokering so I've felt this personally
just running our own org you know yeah I
remember having the conversation you and
I and being like hey let's never sell
our list to anyone because it really
pains me to think about someone who
donated five bucks to us or signed up
for an email list and all of a sudden
they're getting spammed by all these
other candidates or it works or causes
even though some of them I'm sure are
great candidates or org for causes but I
was like I just seem like a raw deal to
you and me so we for went any kind of
payout on the base of our list thank
goodness because you know would have
been a shitty thing to do in my mind it
would have been a violation of trust and
hypocritical but but I'm sure that like
folks are getting targeted anyway
because of publicly available data
because that's just the nature of
donation and that pains me to it's like
that that's like an aspect of what we're
talking about which is that at this
point we are ourselves almost like a
product that's just getting sold and
resold to anyone who thinks that they
can get a bit of our attention and money
so those are two major major concerns in
my mind one is the sanctity and efficacy
of our democracy in a true way like
whether that's being subverted number
two is the economics are all wrong for
individuals and then number three is
something we talked about with gene and
other people and Aaron and we touched on
it just now but this entire Zoo is
really bad for our mental health we're
like you have these billion dollar
organizations constantly trying to like
target your attention
and it ends up if you're an adult enzyme
numbing you we're just like like you
know what is someone trying to get my
attention about today if you're in
certain groups you actually become less
well less healthy and Jaron talks about
this gerund said that and he's right
that negative sentiments and emotions
spread more powerfully via social media
than in other ways and so social media
is serving to make us all more irritable
and more paranoid and this is a
byproduct of the fact that these
companies know so much about us they
target us they follow us around and so
that's why many of us have this sinking
feeling that we're like rats in a maze
and then we're getting peppered with
little like bits of cheese or
breadcrumbs like just getting pegged at
our heads all the time this is one
reason why Jared's like hey you know
it'd be better it's like you've just
unplugged but for many people it's not
realistic to unplug entirely and this
has having a particularly disastrous
effect on our young people where rates
of anxiety and depression have surged
among teenagers and teenage girls in
part because we're letting ourselves get
pushed into this environment where our
attention is the commodity like every
click and every action we take is
getting sold and resold to people who
want to reach us and the experience that
Jaron contrasted all this with is
something like Netflix where you pay for
Netflix and then Netflix tries to serve
you movies and like TV shows that they
think you'll like but it's not like
you're getting bombarded with
third-party ads when you're in Netflix
so like so net so Netflix seems like a
fine whole experience and so Jaron was
suggesting it's like you know what if we
actually were forced to pay for a
Facebook and then you just dial down all
of the selling and reselling of our data
all of the advertisements then it would
be a completely different experience
because the incentives of the
organization change
[Music]
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by Tommy
John what is Tommy John Tommy John is
ultra cool cotton underwear that's
designed so that it helps like operate
as a cooling system for the summer so if
you're the type of person that gets
sweaty and warm easily you should check
out Tommy John underwear Zak's been a
fan since before they sent us free stuff
I had this dream Andrew that we would
start a podcast together and on this
podcast we would sell underwear and now
we are living that dream and to be
honest with you Tommy John underwear is
badass
I learned this about not from these guys
my brother is a huge fan he's like just
don't buy anything but Tommy John it
works it's breathable no sweat no
nothing I felt like an underwear model I
put it on I was like wow this is like
slimming feeling good you know saying I
don't know wow dude Wow Spanx for men
alright so for a limited time go to
Tommy John comm slash yang to get 20%
off site-wide that's Tommy John comm /
yang for 20% off site-wide seaside for
details get your trousers your your
bracket your underwear at Tommy John
Tommy John comm / yang that's a good
deal - these are good underwear high
quality 20% offs a big deal
[Applause]
you want us I'm crazy we had this a
couple adding she's come up just during
the campaign I've had this in other
organs I've run to is that this ad
agency was telling us that they can
track us apparently anonymously your web
traffic and to know basically the
cookies on a on a web browser but what
they did is they segmented people based
on basically likeliness and correlations
to do certain activities so what they
could tell they could segment their
consumer so if you read business insider
they would also know that you're likely
to buy a subaru and likely to shop at
freshly calm or whatever it is and they
have hundreds of thousands of these
segmentations and one i don't believe
that it was anonymous but to like it's
really creepy what they can learn about
you it's driving us nuts but it also
like there's some sort of bigbrother
aspect to that that i've never really
felt comfortable with
well it certainly it makes you feel much
less unique and like an individual it's
like oh snap I also read Business
Insider and drive a Subaru and you find
out predictable you are fair fair enough
so those are some of the big problems
that like the I'd say those are the big
three there are others is like you know
our democracy being subverted the fact
that billions and tens of billions of
dollars are changing hands and we are
seeing none of it and then the fact that
this is all bad for our culture our
society our mental health our kids
mental health it leads us almost to
interact with the world like we are
ourselves like a product and it's
dehumanizing we're sanding down all of
the things that make people distinct and
and human even like the the word content
now it's like you and I are having this
conversation you know and we're
obviously digitizing it it's a podcast
and you know be it be out there on the
internet and the word content is now
being applied to just about really
anything that that commands your
attention for like a moment it's like
whoa that was like I'm moving
performance like good content so that's
true so the so the big question is what
the heck can we do about all of this
given that we are completely outgunned
by these tech companies these billion
trillion dollar tech companies that are
in our government obviously is nowhere
on the scene like our government is just
looking up like a trained seal going art
and like clapping its hands being like
you know and and the issues that our
government chases down are built not on
any systemic approaches but it's just
like a headline or a tweet or like you
know Donald Trump didn't like the fact
that Twitter fact-checked a couple of
his tweets so then he like signed some
phantom weird executive order based on a
25 year old law that you know was was
made before Facebook even existed you
know it was applied to like geo cities
or whatever like our like in theory our
government would have a more intelligent
approach to all this but our government
they're complicit man like how many
elected officials are getting elected or
raising money because of Facebook ads
right now they have no incentive to
regulate this yeah I don't have a
problem you know I mean I'm a problem
with the fact that they're so behind on
regulating like certainly if you're
using Facebook ads and using them well
like it's okay because how else you
gonna reach people at this point like
one of the things I figured out when I
was running yeah my education company
was we were spending a ton of money on
Facebook Google Facebook particular and
at one point I realized that Facebook is
like a proxy for the internet if you're
trying to reach people because you know
like they'll be on it like many many
people of particular demographics will
be on it significantly every day and so
we were trying to reach people you just
like pumped your $1.00 into it it
reminds me a little bit of the dialing
for dollars that politicians do where
it's like you just sit there and like
soulless Lee call donors and ask for
money and it's the worst thing in the
world I hated doing it but then when
you're in their part of the system
you're like well now I'm kind of good at
it so do I want to do away with a system
that enables me to like stab off any any
newcomer it's like now that I'm in here
and I've got my call list like like that
this is like my moat it's it's very dark
and very screwed up so for the end of
Jools who are listening this being like
okay i buy that this is a problem we've
been slipping down this slope for a
while now what are we gonna do about it
so we're gonna be talking to a friend of
mine for years who's now leading the
data dividend project which humanity
forward is very proud to be front and
center on and a part of and we're
launching this project to try and
activate the data property rights for
everyone listening to this right now
that when I was running for president I
said look your data is yours and if
anyone's profiting from it it should be
you you should have certain rights that
are common sense we all understand you
should know what is happening to your
data you should know if it's being sold
or resold you should be able to turn it
off if you want you should be able to
move it to another place if you want so
you're not trapped with a particular
company forever and you should be able
to share in the value now I'm excited to
say that this is no longer hypothetical
California and Nevada have passed laws
saying that consumers have these rights
and in California the law went into
effect January 1 of 2020 and it will
start being enforced July 1 of 2020
which is like freaking you know the next
week or two two weeks yeah yeah so if
you want to get in on this consumer
revolution to take back our data
property rights go to DDP for all calm
and all you need to do is give us like
you know just a few basic pieces of info
and say check the box being like yes I
want you to fight for my data rights
with the tech companies and we will then
take a unified front to the tech
companies and say look you all of these
people information on what the heck
you're doing with the data what's
happening to it who's getting it the
ability to turn it off the ability to
move it and what kind of money are you
making because our people deserve it
it's their data it should be their money
too so this is the big announcement so
we have launched with demanding forward
led by Andrew what we're calling the
data dividend project DDP and we're
going to try to get you
the American people paid for your data
because apparently no one's doing this
so we're gonna try it and all you have
to do is go to DDP for all calm and you
sign up very quickly I just did it today
it's like name email your city and then
you sign like you agree that we will
fight for you and then as soon as we can
and it could be two months it could be a
year who knows but we will basically
gather as many users as we can and go to
these tech companies and fight and get
you paid so that's the dream it's pretty
exciting Andrew and surprising no one's
tried to do this yet and we're excited
to be I think it's a role that you play
Andrew and that you can be a trusted
source like no you're clearly we don't
even part from my own data right that
even though we could like we're clearly
in this for humanity forward reasons to
try to get people paid for the data
they're not getting paid for it maybe
never will no one does anything they're
not getting paid for at this time well
the great thing Zack is there's so many
parts of the puzzle we can accelerate so
this is a law that's on the books in
California the tech companies are trying
to lobby to have it enforced in really
pathetic watered-down ways as you can
guess but in California the laws on the
books it can be enforced Nevada same
thing in New York Texas other states are
looking at it and thinking they should
follow California's lead and have the
same law on the books so we can ramp up
the pressure on state legislatures to
pass something like the California
consumer Privacy Act in their states and
if you're a state legislature or why the
heck wouldn't you do this like look out
fear people look out for your consumers
and citizens like California did like
Nevada did and so you can see the tech
companies are looking up being like oh
like what does this mean for us
it could be enormous ly transformative
and we can be at the frontier pushing
that to state legislatures because we
can go thanks to you all who signed up a
DDP for all calm we can be like look we
represent hundreds of thousands even
millions of American consumers these are
the people in your state in your
district that care and I want this let's
get it done and then after we get the
rules in
place then we can actually start carving
up the pie in a way that makes sense for
consumers because again you click click
click you think oh it's free it's free
but then like you get this sinking
feeling it's like whoa there's actually
not the sweet sweet deal I thought it
was it is not the sweet sweet deal you
thought it was and we're gonna make it
so it is a sweet sweet deal but you can
actually start resting easy on the fact
that your data is not being mishandled
or sold to folks you don't want it sold
to that you're gonna get money for every
time any money gets generated from your
data which is all the time
we'll be able to sleep easier knowing
that our democracy is actually
functioning better for the fact that
we're not all getting just like sold
crap like rats in a maze and and the
rest of it and we may even be able to
help look out for the mental health of
our kids and ourselves so there are
enormous upsides to this initiative this
revolution and I'm I'm just excited that
we can play such an important role
because when this came up I looked at it
and I was like wait this laws on the
books what like why aren't people
rallying around this and then you look
around and be like who exactly would
rally people around this the tech
companies obviously don't want to touch
it
you know the technicals are trying to
bury it most politicians don't
understand these issues terribly well
and - except they do understand these
issues it's like well I represent some
particular state it's like is this
really front and center for my people it
should be front and center for us as a
country and I am thrilled to be leading
this fight I hope that you sign up I
hope that anyone listening to this if
you have friends you're like yo sign up
at DDP for all calm because there's zero
downside and you might get money and
might cause a consumer revolution to
have us all be treated like human beings
instead of rats and amazed this is
particularly true if you have friends in
California and Nevada because we might
be able to get them cold hard cash in a
reasonable timeframe because these tech
companies have legal obligations in
those states that they are not living up
to this is what I'm so excited about
like what a cool vision where we finish
the campaign and now we start getting
people actually paid for the data they
should be getting paid for that's the
dream that's the vision DDP for all calm
and you talk about it with Enoch and the
rest of this episode yeah so I sit down
with the CEO of the data dividend
project he's one of the foremost
litigators in the country it's very
handy because you know at some point you
do need to sit down and negotiate and
hammer out settlements and deals with
these companies so thrilled to be
working with him to activate our data
property rights what I love about this
is like it's not frankly like the
political [ __ ] it was like oh we
should do something about it like we
actually can do something about it
together that's one thing I really pride
pride this organization on and myself on
is like I never wanted to be a dude who
talked about [ __ ] like I see myself as
as like a man of action
now sometimes talking is an action and I
get that but being able to actually
fight for people's data rights for real
makes me so happy you know that the fact
that we're distributing economic relief
I think when we're now past the five
million dollar mark thank you to
everyone who donated to humanity forward
but it's one thing to stand up and say
hey we should be giving people money
during this time which we should clearly
than any member of Congress who's not
for emergency cash relief she got voted
out and we need to vote someone in who
understands what the heck is going on
but then we don't just talk about it we
do it we're like hey you know now like
tens of thousands of people have gotten
micro grants thanks to our generous
donors you know suing the state of New
York when they tried to like have it so
that people couldn't vote I mean like
that was [ __ ] and so instead of
being like that's wrong but being like
hey let's just try and fix that so the
data property rights is the biggest
example of this where it's like we can
talk about it we can do something about
it if enough let's get together we can
100% hold these companies feet to the
fire change the practices put pressure
on legislators they have to actually do
the right thing we can spoon feed them
the information about it because if they
don't understand it we get enough people
excited about it then they'll just be
like okay what's my downside of
emulating this California law or
eventually passing federal legislation
for better for worse more and more
people are waking up
- the fact that free is not the deal we
thought it was and that there are real
costs in economic terms are called
externalities there are massive
externalities to the arrangements we've
made where we have some of the biggest
companies in the world that are
ad-supported and like that the
advertising model has some real
drawbacks some real problems
imagine for a moment if you had Netflix
and it was ad supported like hey Netflix
is free but you go on there and then all
of a sudden you got bombarded with [ __ ]
like you know like people just try to
sell you stuff right and left like
Netflix would suck like it's really
interesting to have as like a contrast
it's like you know like if you had paid
Netflix and free Netflix paid Netflix is
like infinitely better than than free
Netflix or like quote unquote free but
ad-supported correct
you know Jaron said it he's like looked
up and said hey we needed a business
model and we chose ad-supported and
we're like well that seemed like a fine
choice at the time but now that choice
has been revved up to this insane degree
that threatens to turn us on each other
make us completely incoherent and to
make it so that our democracy no longer
functions so today we talk about the day
to David end project GDP for all com
Andrew sits down with Enoch the CEO of
the data dividend project tell you about
how it works why it's important and
frankly how we can scale this around the
country and get you paid for your data
let's go get that money
you all know Andrew Young is about
getting people that money this is
another way we can get you that money
I'm all about it I hope you're all about
it too and yeah excited to sit down with
Enoch
coming up after the break
my conversation with the CEO of the day
to dividend project and the brilliant
the innovative Enoch Liang what if you
don't want to go out but you need a
stamp and you're not gonna believe this
but there's a company that's gonna
address that problem for you and it is
called stamps calm yep if you go to
Stan's calm you could propose to John
the man
skip the line skip the crowd skip the
mask you can save some money even and if
that wasn't enough stamps calm offers
UPS service with discounts of up to 62
percent and no surcharges
so that's stamps calm it's gonna bring
the post office right to your computer
and the safety of your own home it's
very 21st century I mean I'm actually a
fan of the post office but I'm an even
bigger fan if you can just print it out
on your computer because that's just a
win for us all right now listeners to
yang speaks can a special offer that
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale without
any long-term commitment you can weigh
yourself on the scale no you can't
because it's not that kind of scale just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
yang that stamps comm enter yang let's
keep you safe and sound with stamps in
your pocket Thank You stamps calm
[Music]
[Applause]
very excited to welcome to yank speaks
my old and dear friend FINA clang Enoch
how are you I'm good I'm good thanks for
having me Andrew yeah it's great to see
you
so Enoch is the CEO and co-founder of
the data dividend project now what the
heck is that we're about to get into it
but Enoch and I know each other because
we were law school classmates in the
late 90s Enoch went on to become one of
the most accomplished litigators in the
country so when we were in law school
learning like Enoch actually took it to
heart and figured out how to become an
accomplished trial lawyer and litigator
while I ended up becoming an
entrepreneur who hires lawyers because
because I don't trust myself you've been
doing pretty uh pretty good in
litigation yourself lately yes what I
know against the New York State Board of
Elections thanks for noticing man we
didn't even need to get you so one thing
I said all the time on the trail was
that data is the new oil that our data
is now the most valuable asset in the
world and we are none the wiser we're
not seeing a dime of it yes Andrew
taking that analogy one step further if
you were to imagine that the tech
companies are each like they've each
built their own car with their own
proprietary engine but that car isn't
going to go anywhere without fuel what's
the fuel of the 21st century it's data
right and that data fuel right now we're
just giving it away for free
and powering these tech companies
engines to just make more and more and
more money extract more and more and
more value and I think something that
Americans don't know about is that tech
companies are taking our data directly
that data fuel and putting it in their
car but they're also going out and
buying it they're going and buying it
from gas stations otherwise known as
data brokers or data resellers and not
only are we giving the fuel directly to
the tech companies but these data
brokers and resellers are selling it to
the tech companies at gas stations and
we
seeing any value from that either yeah
and and this gets even darker when you
realize that these mammoth tech
companies are paying zero or near zero
in taxes very often times and so the
public's really getting squeezed of
value in more ways than one it's
incredible that our leaders are so
behind the times that we're just looking
around saying yeah this is appropriate
it's completely unacceptable what we've
allowed to happen yeah and I that
reminds me of something I think that you
either said on the debate stage or in
the interviews which is our government
is like literally 25 years behind
because 25 years ago when you and I were
in law school and first met each other
was when the government Department of
Technology regulation was abolished
that's what the office of Technology
Assessment they got rid of it in the mid
late 90s so we're now flying blind and
our legislators don't have a clue about
technology because they just get their
information from the tech companies
right so one of the things that I was
passionate about on the campaign trail
which now you are going to become one of
the leading champions in the world on is
data as a property right our data should
be ours even if we decide to loan it out
and the exciting thing is it seems like
the state of California and some other
places agree the California Consumer
Privacy Act gives California consumers a
bundle of rights that relate to data
privacy and data as property and my
guess is your policy people were
actually referring to the CCPA before it
went into effect yeah yeah completely
we're very open to finding work other
people have done so this went into
effect in January what rights does it
give the people of California well a
couple of rights and I'll just go into
them the first one is the right to know
what personal information is collected
used shared and sold the right to delete
personal information held by businesses
about consumers the right to opt out of
the sale of personal information and
then the right to non-discrimination in
terms of prices or service of goods when
a consumer exercised a privacy right
under the CCPA so I'm guessing that the
vast majority of people
have never heard of this stuff and so
what they're thinking is like okay how
does this affect me so first is this
only in California there are other
states that either have done something
similar or are doing something similar
Maine and Nevada currently have laws on
the books and there's about another 10
to 12 states that are considering data
privacy legislation like Arizona Hawaii
Illinois Maryland New Hampshire New
Jersey New York South Carolina Texas so
this is starting to become a thing well
a good thing because if you're the
consumer you're completely in the dark
you get some I agree or I can send
button that comes up with a bunch of
mumbo-jumbo and you skip the mumbo-jumbo
and you click that button and then you
use that service and then you just hope
that nothing goes wrong later and then
occasionally you get notified that
there's been some breach or hack or you
get fed ads everywhere you go where
you're like huh I was just emailing my
cousin about a parka and then all of a
sudden I'm getting parka ads the case
maybe so that's the way most people
interact with this stuff you know in
reality it really isn't a choice if you
think about it you spend $300 on a
smartphone and sign up for $50 a month
of phone and data service and you come
home and you turn on that phone and the
first screens that come up are these
end-user license agreements and these
privacy policies in these terms and
conditions and you and I are lawyers
Andrew and I'll tell you what I would
have a very hard time reading that and
figuring it out and if you don't click
agree then that expensive smartphone
that you just bought isn't going to work
so it's really you know not a choice at
all you just paid hundreds of dollars
for this smartphone and you have to go
through all these licenses before before
it even turns on and works and it's the
same for almost every app that you
download right and so I think Americans
have just become desensitized to these
terms and conditions and privacy
policies where they just click agree
agree agree and hope for the best so I
completely agree with you I agree with
you it's like a false choice or an
illusion of choice because let's say you
don't agree or you don't consent what
the heck happens next I mean no one
knows you just
back out and then you don't use this
thing called the Internet yeah I mean
could you imagine if you applied this to
real life and be like you go into the
car dealership and you buy a car and
before you drive off the lot you have to
agree to 50 pages of terms and
conditions and one of them is we can by
the way track you everywhere you go
and we can use that location data from
tracking you to serve you ads and
basically follow you everywhere I think
Americans would revolt if that was the
case with when they buy a car but that's
that's the way the Internet has been
essentially built from the beginning and
it's only getting worse you know what is
going wrong right now like if I'm a
consumer and I just agreed to everything
and was like whatever maybe I get served
ads well it's more than that right the
data that that is being collected and
sold and resold about American consumers
is used for all kinds of things it's
used for credit scores it's used for
health insurance premiums it's used for
automobile premiums and you know
sometimes that data that's collected is
wrong it might be for somebody else
named Andrew yang there are a lot of us
out there I feel bad for the other ones
I should be excited for them I guess but
anyway and and so you don't know why
your credit score is going down you
don't know why your premiums are going
up and you don't really have a recourse
for it to me the thing that I find
offensive is that my data gets sold and
resold and packaged and repackaged and
people are making money off it and I'm
not I mean isn't it my data like if
someone's making money it should be me
and it could be that if someone's making
money and they say look I'm making money
you wouldn't make this money without me
maybe we split it like I would find that
at least somewhat more acceptable than
somehow my data is yours to profit from
I think that the more Americans are
educated about this process the more
outraged they are going to feel you know
for example there's an entire data
brokering and data reselling industry
out there that's a 200 billion dollar a
year industry and unlike let's say a
Google or a Facebook or an Amazon these
data brokers and data
sellers are not providing consumers with
any goods or services oh my gosh it's
just a secondary market for data and
they make money and that's it and like
we don't get any of that exactly they
don't provide us any goods or services
and they're just making money off the
backs of American consumers data and
sometimes it's you know very very
private information that you wouldn't
want to share for example data brokers
it's been publicly reported our selling
lists of people who have taken
antidepressants in the past or whether
you're an alcoholic or whether you or
someone in your family has cancer or
heart disease or hypertension whether
you're gay or straight whether you have
a eating disorder and outrageously
whether you were the victim of sexual
assault this is the type of very very
private data that goes beyond just the
census level data that data brokers and
data resellers are selling and reselling
and packaging about Americans and the
most valuable category is healthcare
data like if you know what's going on
with me and my need for insulin or
antidepressants that's very very
profitable so so that's the current
state of affairs and does this
California law change that state of
affairs for the consumer um it does for
the individual consumer because the
individual consumer like we said can
exercise his or her right to deletion
his or her right to opt out but it's
going to take a movement and it's gonna
take collective action to change things
on a broader scale so like these laws
they inks barely dry on this law and
then I go to Facebook and say hey I've
got the right to know I've got the right
to delete I'm gonna exercise them like
right now can I do that you can an
individual can certainly go and wade
through the privacy policy or the terms
and conditions on a Twitter or let's say
a data broker and exercise your right to
know what data is being collected about
you your right to delete and your right
to opt out so has anyone tried that
there they're definitely tech
journalists who have exercised their
rights under the CCPA and then
about it one tech journalist actually
exercised her rights under the CCPA for
facial recognition and some of the stuff
that came back was actually pretty scary
because it wasn't all her so it has
happened because the law is brand-new
the law gives corporations quite a bit
of time to respond at least initially
and then you know after the first year
or so then the time to respond becomes
shorter and shorter but there are
individuals that have done that and have
reported on it but I think you and I
both agree that it's not like we should
all become our own data cops because one
we have better things to do but two
we're completely outgunned yeah exactly
and and that's kind of what sparked the
idea for the data dividend project or as
we like to call it DDP after one of my
favorite pro wrestler is Diamond Dallas
Page that's right maybe that'll help
some people remember it so you know
Andrew I'm not a data privacy lawyer but
I have to say when I heard you speaking
on the trail about how data is more
valuable than oil and how there
hoovering it up and monetizing it that
caused me to go and actually take a
deeper dive into this and I spoke to
some data privacy lawyers and I read the
statutes and thought wow this is
something that's affecting all Americans
it's affecting all consumers this is
something that's really important that
Americans should know about and that's
what was kind of the genesis that led to
DDP now so what is DDP if I'm a consumer
that wants to activate my newfound data
property rights like what do I do
well DDP is a movement to basically
harness the collective bargaining power
of all California consumers and
eventually all Americans it sounds like
because if you're in Nevada mean okay
eventually New York New Hampshire all
these other places exactly we didn't
have a choice when it came to clicking
agree agree agree and it's a false
choice either you agreed to the
licensing terms or your smartphone
didn't work or you're living in a cabin
in the woods exactly well the idea is to
build a movement with you know hundreds
of thousands if not millions of
consumers
that tech companies don't have a choice
but to listen to us and that collective
action that collective bargaining
component is what DDP is trying to
harness and you know the technology
companies have banded up and explicitly
tried to weaken the CCPA I bet well you
know if you're a big uns giant tech
company you're like and let's not give
you these rights that would be fantastic
I'm making money I don't really need to
deal with this headache right and that
is one reason that the California
privacy rights act is on the ballot in
November 2020 is because you know the
CCPA got watered down by the tech
companies lobbyists and so the CPRA
is on the ballot to kind of restore
those rights and create a California
privacy protection agency so if there's
a movement and there's a lobbying group
by the technology companies then there
needs to be a movement by the consumers
and that's what DDP is creating now and
so everyone knows humanity forward is
partnered with DDP to make this happen
because we believe I believe and there's
no other way to make it happen except to
get a bunch of us together and go have
let's say world-class lawyers and
negotiators sit down with the tech
companies and say hey here are our
property rights under the law and you
are not complying or we have hundreds of
thousands of people that want to be able
to audit their data
want to be able to share in the value so
if there's an individual that wants to
join this movement what do they do where
do they go they can go to
DDP for all calm and fill out the form
there then you'll be part of the
movement DDP and then the words for all
fo are aol.com yep DDP fo r al comm and
so I take it if I go to DDP for all com
that they'll be like you know a little
explaining why not but this thing is
free how long does it take what do I
actually do when I get there it's free
to sign up for and when you get there
you put in the information that the
technology companies are going to
require from DDP to exercise your rights
collectively so what's that that's like
my name what is it yeah it will be your
name your address your
number as many emails as you can
remember that you've used I'm old school
so I have a I have an old school yahoo
email but that I don't use as much now
but I also have a gmail I have a hotmail
- is there a technical term for like our
AO L or hotmail or yahoo accounts that
we give to companies we don't want to
hear from it's like the retail checkout
email what's that I'm at Banana Republic
you want an email address sure thing
Andrew yang one one three at hotmail
that's how I you vote yes we should come
up with a term for that
there yes should be it should be like
that phone number that you know you give
to someone at a bar you don't want
actually to call you is there a name as
their name for that not that that's ever
happened to me I've just heard about
this used to happen to me all the time
what was like the term for that things I
guess it's just fake number yeah we're
added we should talk about like the
hierarchy of email address suffixes
where you know if someone says this is
my email address then you judge them so
I feel like yahoo is acceptable still in
a way that AOL and hotmail are not Gmail
is obviously the premium and then like
at me or mail calm like those are cool
that's like there's someone should just
come up with a hierarchy for this stuff
and what it says about you especially to
like younger people and Millennials
right well I'll tell you if you have a o
L that means you're probably older and
probably means you vote so those are the
people I needed to be hunting down I
needed to get to the freaking AOL
universe anyway you show up at DDP for
all calm you fill in your basic info
some old email addresses right and then
you sign what's known as an authorized
agent agreement which designates DDP to
act as your authorized agent to exercise
your rights under the CCPA so how long
does that take DDP we're all calm this
whole thing three minutes I just tested
it myself the other day the hardest the
hardest part about it was trying to
remember my old email addresses all
right so I spent three minutes at DDP
for all calm and then what and then we
need to reach a critical mass in order
to
exercise collective action and so if
only one or two or ten or fifteen or
even a thousand people are exercising
their rights I think the technology
companies and the data brokers are going
to ignore that it's going to take a
critical mass of you know hundreds of
thousands if not millions of people in
order to you know really hit them where
it counts well I'm sure we can get that
many people because a lot of people are
going to agree with you and me on this
but if I'm a user and I sign up three
minutes after that am i all set you know
if you want to sign up for a newsletter
or if you want to come visit our blog
once in a while so we can keep you
informed about legislative developments
in your state that's an option that you
can check when you sign up but um other
than that hopefully we'll be reporting
back on good news what does that news
even look like what like what what does
victory look like well I think victory
the long-term goal of GDP is to
eventually create an exchange so if you
highly value your privacy don't want
anybody to track your online activity
ever then you can go totally dark on
this exchange but if you're okay with
sharing some of your data and receiving
targeted advertising in exchange then
you can go on and turn on some tracking
and in return you'll get what what's
called a data dividend maybe some type
of small payment the ultimate point and
this is what DDP wants to accomplish is
that it's your personal choice about
your personal privacy right now none of
us have any personal choice about our
privacy online so you're saying that if
someone goes to DDP for all com signs up
there is a possibility down the road
that they're actually going to achieve
my beautiful vision of sharing in the
spoils from their data so that they'll
actually get cash from DDP if we are
able to bargain with the tech companies
for these rights yes that's absolutely
the goal but again it's gonna take
critical mass to achieve that goal
that's a beautiful vision and that's why
I'm so excited about this is that again
it's our data it's our property if
there's value being generated we should
have it and one reason I'm so excited
about DDP is like I want to get people
that value that money I want millions of
people to sign up at DDP for
and then forget about it for a while and
then get some communication some number
of weeks or months later saying great
news
we've won and here's your money or here
your choices and if you make this choice
here's your money nothing would make me
happier everyone knows andrew yang just
loves giving people money I wish that
that we were just giving people money
right and left and this is a way we can
get people money for their data that
they should have been getting the entire
time that's why I'm so excited about
this now maybe I'm just you know sort of
like I'm primitive but like I think in
those ways I just think like get that
cash get that cheddar get that money get
those data box dividend so I'm all about
it and I you know I got to say when we
talk about gathering critical mass like
my vision is this is that we get a
certain number of people together and
then we have a victory and then they get
some money it doesn't need to be big
money let's call it like 20 bucks but
can you imagine how excited that person
will be did I tell their friends being
like hey you wouldn't believe this I
signed up at DDP for all com forgot
about it for a while I just got 20 bucks
you sign up to maybe you won't get 20
bucks because your data's not as
valuable as mine or maybe I'll get a lot
more and then it will spread like
wildfire but we need to start this
movement and then start getting us our
own value for our data where it belongs
in our hands so yeah man I'm so excited
you came to us at humanity forward with
this because we're gonna be pushing for
this until those data dividends start
flowing back to consumers yeah
absolutely and I think that these times
with the Kovan 19 pandemic is making
this all the more urgent right because
our lives are moving more and more and
more online because we can't see people
face to face as much or as safely I
heard you talking about this article you
read when you had Sam Harris on this
podcast about ten changes that are
accelerated ten technological changes
that are accelerated because of kovin 19
and man every single one of those
technological changes
involves data privacy data rights data
as property and now is more urgent than
ever that we get started on retaking
what should have been ours in the first
place and this is the perfect time
because the California law goes into
effect essentially right now Nevada law
right now Maine law right now and then
all of these other states are going to
follow suit soon so if you're in a state
that has not been mentioned here feel
free to reach out to your state
legislators your reps being like hey you
know what you should do just like draft
the California law and throw it on the
books who's gonna be against this you
know what I mean it's like every
consumer is gonna be like heck yes we
should have that right as a presidential
candidate I was saying we should just
federalize it but no need to wait we can
do this right now it's on the books in
states around the country and even if
you're not in California and Maine or
Nevada you can still come to GDP for
allcom and sign up so that we can
contact you when legislation in your
state starts moving or better yet you
know we can contact you about how to
write your state senator your state
Congress person to get legislation like
this introduced in the first place
[Applause]
what's at stake timmy is fundamental
it's not just the the money though I'm
all about the money but it's it's about
our agency as human beings it's about
the way we make decisions someone called
it data dignity you know right now we
are being essentially sold off as
commodities and it's dehumanizing you
know we need to have agency we also need
to make sure that the decisions were
making are ours and it's not that we're
just being led through a digital maze
like freaking rats you know or they just
keep like hitting you with various
things and you're like oh yeah like and
you know you think you're making choices
but really it's because they've been
influencing you with dozens and dozens
of messages and contacts you know it's
like if that's gonna happen then we at
least need to be aware of it and
partners in it and profit from it
absolutely and I'm glad you brought up
the data dignity and the data is a human
right idea because you know this really
goes back to privacy and property right
privacy is a fundamental human right
that should be enjoyed by everyone like
free speech right to a fair trial
etc like for example in California the
California Constitution actually gives
each person the inalienable right to
pursue and obtain privacy and in today's
online world there's literally zero
privacy unless you know you're using a
VPN blocker or some type of search
engine like DuckDuckGo so one way to
restore that privacy is to make sure
that people own their own data your data
should be your property and I think that
everybody understands this in the
offline world but in real life like if
you have a house you have the right to
control who uses that land you have the
right to keep people off of it maybe one
person values her privacy greatly so she
posts a no trespassing no soliciting
sign puts her mailbox all the way down
the street away from her house that's
her right because that's her property
may be another person's okay with sales
people coming and knocking on his or her
door occasionally but imagine if the
online world's rules applied to real
life you'd buy a house but in this house
anybody can come in listen to your
conversation
see what medications of vitamins you're
taking write down what you watch on your
TV see what articles you're reading in
the newspaper and then they would use
that to target ads to you you know we've
never put up with that in real life I
don't know why we put up with that
online yeah we shouldn't you know we
need to actually get our arms around the
practices that have been in place for
years I am pumped that our lawmakers are
catching up to the 21st century and that
we're here just in the nick of time the
perfect time really to build this
movement
DDP for all com hopefully we're gonna
get millions of Americans activated and
we're gonna fight for your rights to do
whatever the heck you want without
anyone knowing what's going good look
that was like a beastie boys we're going
to fight fear anyway we're here to fight
for your right to party online that's a
good motto yeah I'm gonna I'm dating
myself a little bit whatever people
still know the Beasties I hope I don't
know Enoch and I are contemporaries so
he mix down well I am so glad to be your
champion and partner in this I'm
grateful to you for fighting for
consumer rights in this way and grateful
to you for coming to us with this data
dividend project we're gonna make it
happen for millions of Americans and
it's because folks like you actually
decided to do something about it so
Thank You Enoch I'm so glad that we've
been friends these years that my friends
are doing such cool freakin stuff you
know it's like instead of having friends
who are like hey you know here's some
[ __ ]
my friends are like let's fight for
people's data property rights let's get
ourselves our own agency and autonomy
back let's have us sharing the value so
I'm really just thrilled to be working
with you on this and thank you Andrew
for everything that you're doing for
America especially during this time of
pandemic I know that humanity forward
has been giving away money through EBI
and through Kovich pandemic relief and
we really in his inspiration to not just
me but millions of Americans out there
so thank you oh thanks unique you know
to say that but I appreciate a man let's
do it let's make it a fair fight let's
make it the people versus the tech
companies and not just the person so I'm
thrilled to fight this fight with you
let's do it
[Music]